Welcome to LWIAY! The brand-new original show that we're done episode
14!! [Actually, it's the 15 episode, because he forgot about the "The Pewdiepie Song(s)" video.]
Wow, time goes by fast when you're having fun. Isn't that right? At least I haven't done
379 of these. 14 [15.] is not such a bad number all the sudden...
Hope you enjoyed the original intro. It's made by Day by Dave. Thank you very much now
Let's go into the memes if you want to submit your meme, the link is in the description
Don't be shy I know you're sitting on a really good meme for a while now, and you haven't submitted it
How are you gonna become?
Anywhere in life if you haven't submitted to the PewDiePie submission yet clearly you're doing wrong things in life
You haven't gotten anywhere. This could be your hit
This could be your make it moment you could submit a meme. That would get upvotes on the pewdiepie subreddit
Do you understand the opportunities that I am presenting to you, okay?
This is not me taking content from you. This is me giving you
Opportunities you are welcome. I know I am a saint
I am the nicest guy ever nice guy PewDiePie Christian Channel. Let's go
Remember happy wheels this is it now feel old yet?
original content original game ideas
Be careful you call ugly in middle school. What do we got lost oh?
Very Nice..good old giggle
Only true PewDiePie fans will understand this meme okay only only
hardcore watch every single video everyday twice, to increase his watch time
Pewdiepie fans fam squads
post the dankest memes you can find the bros squad fam hold my beer
skrattar du
Yeah, this pretty much summarizes the whole reddit, good job everybody!
Can't tell if it's a good thing or if it's just sad.
Did you laugh or did you lose?
Hey, man, it's a simple question I still don't--
I haven't gotten a single person answering a second times the cha-
oh HERE WE GO AGAIN
Well done, I need to do another green screen soon.. Let me let me do that for next time.
wait what the fuck
wait what the f**k???
Did you laugh or did you lose? I don't even get the meme. It's a loss meme you guys aren't ahead of me
I know hahaha, I understand the meme haha
I get it,
EA-- ee -- OH! I see it now!
*Laughs in Swedish*
Well done.. pft, poor EA I mean no, there's no poor EA..
Well-written structured original joke.. loss
It's kind of true, I don't know why it's funny don't think about it too much it gets weird
Do you ever look at stuff and wonder how he got there? It's been a tough year ok it's been
It's not been the best year for 2017 okay
I didn't let's just say I don't want to relive it.
Could this compete with Pewd's chair-- esscuse mehh
ESCUSE ME
This chair is much BETTER
CAN THE CHAIR DO THIS?
I DON'T THINK SO!
the chair is 399 -- and I'm --
Perfect holiday gift for you and your friends
"who wore it better--" pss
eugh, that's it that's a thick A$$
Stranger yung lean shirt, and I will not have you discriminate it for some sort of Disney product. Thank you very much
How would you even get in and out of that huh pathetic guys if I installed Windows 7 of?
32 bits 2 times will it become 64 bits help please yes, but it will also become Windows 14.
I don't think this was meant to be this dark
Shoot The Kids
Hang The Family
Frame Them All
Christian channel, please what no one no one saw --
Shoot the kids--
hang the family--
f r a m e  D e m
graduating from MIT, watching all seasons of Rick and Morty--
understanding PewDiePie's stance on net neurtality
EUGH ehehe oh man--
I had to take the video down and correct myself because I was literally arguing agai- for net neutrality but
Accidentally against at the same time. It's a it's a complicated a lot of people don't understand
It's the kind of you laugh, or did you laugh?
Or did you lose kind of thing and not a lot of people you need to have a pretty much this level of IQ
Perspective on Pewds, what his parent think he does?
What his viewer thinks he does how to remove copyright claim 100% solved what Marzia thinks he does respect women
What the media thinks he does? This is a very accurate so far what the haters thinks he does PewDiePie spi--
That's actually true what he actually does--
Just read off how to videos good job everybody
rich female celebrities with hair like this have a
125 per chance I'm telling you how oppressed women are hey, I don't have that haircut anymore
hey, I'm not a wahmen
I respect them that doesn't mean.
Well, This is just science again. That's true. It's science its scientific
It must be hard it must be hard ok. Oh wait did
I just self diss damn it
While watching PewDiePie videos after a week watching PewDiePie's videos every day
Watching the video right after making it public so you managed to watch the original
before it gets demonetised
Yeah now now when I take a video down it just cuts up everyone like
Before you could finish the video even if I took the video down YouTube
2017 everybody not just me who pays the price now, huh?
How 'bout that
When you make a subreddit and your fans just use it to spam the same memes over and over again
I made some mistake fuck shit f**K
I made some mistake
shut the fuc- shut the fuc- shut the f- christian-
Be quiet, be quiet please. Net Neutrality got repealed recently
I was pretty bummed out about it, but I think whoever repealed it, was probably more happy to see it go then
I'm sad to lose it
No, no
You don't did he make this did shenanigans make this is this an original did he just meme his own mean I got layers boy
That's impressive end world hunger end world poverty sue kids for cheating
It was surprising how many of you actually thought they were fine to sue the kid.
Apparently I made another mistake there
The reason why he got sued was because he counterclaimed the video
Which the only option after that is to take legal action so really EPIC Games were just cornered
Oopsie I made a mistake again oopsy-daisy. No one cares, please keep watching
PewDiePie filming his- I never seen this meme oh, I never seen that one
That's really good
Never seen this meme never ever have I seen this meme, please keep posting it if you don't have a core message
That is making a positive impact on the planet what the fuck are you doing?
That's right Sorsha ok I'm making a positive impact. I can't even say it
East Coast West Coast
Please guys, please stop the Nazi memes. It's been eight months
They're gonna make another compilation okay?
They'll make a anniversary edition. I'm sure please stop.
how to reach the ten minute mark quality content get the door
Oh.
Sorry
*Trying to reach 10 minute mark*
Sorry I had to
Make a visit to the restroom. I'm sure my editor will just cut it out
Fuck you pewds. Love though I stopped slavery
I stopped the Nazis. I stopped apartheid I stopp-
That wasn't me why do everyone keep being so salty at me like oh it was your fault
Why are you complaining about demonitize? Am I the one that put the ads in the video? Oh yeah?
No, you're right. I did I undercover uploaded a bunch of okay. I mean let's get really with me now
You know what fuck you fuck you it's a Power Move by the media because they canceled my TV show okay
They're like. Aye, YouTube does whatever we tell them
Bunch of losers let's keep striking, okay, if YouTube kept my show the ad pocalypse would never have happened
YouTube is the fault stop blaming me sexy hiking with PewDiePie. That's awesome Killian Wagner
That's awesome. Thank you very much
That's so dope that's perfect for like a phone background
And we are hitting the final page where the top memes are all
Located. This is the top percent of the 1%
Let's watch original content Fridays with PewDiePie
Let's play oh, I see I'm jumping all over it you're never gonna. Let it go huh?
Me while watching a new pew-
Marzia, why is she doing that?
What is she doing
I've never ever seen her do this. What in the world I respect this meme as a Swistian when you spend three hours
Photoshopping a meme to get five up votes
Yeah, well you need to promote your memes, okay?
It's not just about you got a network for the memes and this one made it somehow
So I don't know listen if you want to make it to the top
You gotta work for it alright the PDP's submission reddit is one of the finest subreddits of all time
It doesn't get better than this it doesn't get better when you're too broke to buy a game
So you just watch people play it on YouTube. This is a microaggression. I think this is a microaggression
Okay, just because you're an african-american gentleman doesn't mean that you have any less access to
Monetary gains new you laughs you lose. Demonitize
Reupl-
Yes, that was good well done, you know what you get a you get an
b64 in review what the fuck
please submit your memes for the next one don't forget to leave a like
this is a family-friendly Christian channel, so do tell all your kids to subscribe watch the video three times and
Get it to trending come on come on. I haven't seen a single one of my videos get to trending in 84 years
Please, squad fam out.